good morning ladies and gentlemen can I
just start by thanking Paul and all his
colleagues for the support that we they
are providing to this effort
I have just come from chairing the sixth
strategic coordinating Group which
encompasses all senior Partners not just
the emergency services within the island
a large and Powerful group all dedicated
to resolving this matter carefully and
sensitively
as has already been identified by the
chief minister we have
moved to the recovery phrase
it is a time to just think briefly about
the families
we have deployed family liaison officers
to those families
but it's vitally important that we are
sensitive to their thoughts
considerations emotions
as we now begin what is it going to be a
meticulous and painstaking search of the
debris left following the explosion
so in terms of the forward look
we have now a very specialist staff not
only in states of Jersey police but also
supported by colleagues in the UK to
start carefully identifying bodies when
and if we find them that that will take
time
so it's important that I am here to
manage people's expectations
particularly on behalf of the family
we are not going to be here for days
we are likely to be here for weeks and
it's important that I make that clear
this morning I spoke to the family
liaison coordinator
who described to me the feelings of
those families and I am really really
Keen to ensure that everybody properly
understands the emotions that they are
currently going going through
so this is not going to happen quickly
it's going to happen carefully and it's
going to happen
sensitively
yes an investigation or investigations
are starting that's inevitable as as you
would expect
we deal with the very very unusual in
the usual way
we want to understand how this has
happened and we are working and
participating with all the services
including health and safety to
understand how this has occurred
um I would just like to finish on two
things uh we we have
uh enormous amounts of effort coming
from various different agencies and and
I just want to put out a special thank
you to our honorary police colleagues
throughout the island who are working so
hard particularly overnight
to keep the cordons there in freezing
cold and wet weather
all together including the Emergency
Services we had 50 staff deployed last
night who continued with the search but
also keeping on into safe around the
accordion my second point is
again and this is a point for Islanders
is we have enough capacity indeed
we are able to deal with any other
eventualities so policing will continue
as usual despite the fact that we are
dealing with a major incident
thank you
thank you all and our continued thoughts
uh with the family of all of those
involved as my colleagues have already
alluded to the ambulance service
continue to support the search efforts
and we will continue to do so as long as
that is needed to ensure the safety of
all those on scene
or hazardous area Response Team
colleagues that arrived yesterday from
the United Kingdom originally from
Southwest Ambulance Service trust and
then from West Midlands Ambulance
Service trust later in the day have been
a welcome asset to support our teams on
scene and our commanders dealing with
the incident and working very closely
with our colleagues in firearm rescue
and the Police Service to ensure the
safety of all those on scene and that
the rescue efforts continue to be
supported as I've said
we are reviewing those Arrangements on a
regular basis and we'll aim to keep them
in place as long as we can
all need to
the ambulance service and the health
service continue to operate as a
business as usual alongside the response
to the incident we do have minimal of
our own resources on scene now in that
command effort to ensure business
continuity and that we can manage any
incidents on Ireland
mustn't say thanks go to all my staff
volunteers and partner agencies for
their efforts to date and their
continuing efforts to support the
ongoing incident thank you
um we've come to the point uh where
we've concluded our prepared statements
so what we'd like to do now is uh invite
questions uh from the media
um we will of course be asking questions
both in the people in the room but I
understand but we also have questions
from people who are joining online and
I'm going to be helped and prompted I
think to to know when the time is to do
to do that and when I ask for you to uh
to ask you a question please could you
let me know who you are who you
represent and who your question is for
thank you very much indeed
um yep please
Dan Johnson from BBC News could we just
try and get clear the figures of how
many people are missing how many bodies
you have how many more people you are
searching for I think that's probably
one best fielded by the the chief
officer of police
okay
the fire service response to that block
of Flats on Friday night what more can
you tell us about that action you'll
understand at the moment uh I I I I'm
not able to add and will not add to the
answer I gave yesterday
um but but what you can absolutely have
is as a guarantee from me my personal
commitment to you that we will be
absolutely honest and transparent and we
will completely
um
provide every item of information that
is required
it's because our most important priority
now is to make sure that we understand
exactly what happened exactly why it
happened
do you accept something must have gone
wrong not at this stage well something
clearly has gone wrong because the
building has exploded and collapsed but
but but and horribly wrong as well but
but at the moment because we are at the
phase that we are at my focus and the
focus of all my colleagues at the moment
is on the thing that we are doing right
now
um
but in terms of an open and Transplant
we will cooperate fully and openly and
transparently with every phase that
happens
how much Faith Can people here have in
the emergency services when they've had
a suspicion about gas they've made that
call they've had somebody out but still
lives have been lost
yes of course it is a tragic tragic
situation and we're all devastated that
that that Islanders have been lost and
that families and loved ones are
suffering today and will continue to do
so with our full support but they will
still suffer and we understand that uh
it's awful
um but Islanders can have confidence in
their Emergency Services Islanders can
have confidence in the states of Jersey
Fire and Rescue service
what Assurance will you give those
families who will want to know how this
happened and if it could have been
prevented and I think the answer is in
your question actually if you don't mind
I I think that I think that what those
families deserve
and what those families will absolutely
receive
is openness and transparency from me on
behalf of my organization every step of
the way
Phil Robert from ITV News uh just
questions to the chief of police as the
operation has now changed from a rescue
to recovery
um is the Assumption sadly that those
people who were counted as missing have
lost their lives
as as the fire chief has indicated we
brought over a number of specialist
assets yesterday and yesterday afternoon
some of which came in Chinooks uh thanks
to the support of the military to bring
in not only those specialist assets but
also sniffer dogs and the like to give
us the confidence that we need that we
have now moved into the recovery phase
so inevitably and tragically and sadly
that is the case
and as was alluded to just now do we
have any idea on on numbers
you'll appreciate this because this is a
very sensitive area and of course it's
very very difficult to be precise
the one area I can be precise on is that
we have three confirmed fatalities
and I think it is fair to say that we
expect to find more
previously we've said probably in the
region of a dozen but you will
understand how difficult it is to make
that assessment but that's that's a
number we hope we don't get to but
that's the number we are just sort of
working to
okay how has the force got on in terms
of contacting next of kin
yes we're confident that we've contacted
the next of kin via our family liaison
officers and of course government very
helpfully brought in a helpline which
has aided that communication as well and
financial question to the Chief Minister
if I may on the response from the island
in terms of coming together and people
providing support and and shops being
open as well providing clothes and food
as well
thank you well as you know we're a very
small but strong community and the
public effort has been quite
extraordinary we've been overwhelmed by
people wishing to help in both practical
and financial ways we we have put on a
call center today and yesterday so that
we can help to coordinate that and
identify any assistance that we can and
in particular through discussions with
the bailiffs chambers the bailiff has
kindly agreed to set up a fund that will
be a collection point for monies that
can be used to support people who've
been displaced and also to help us
respond to the other tragic incidents
that we've experienced amongst us this
week and that was the loss of a trawler
earlier in the week so I think that will
help us greatly as we move forward and
come together as a community
thank you
thank you very much it's uh Julie morale
here from baileywick expression the
Jersey Evening Post could I please ask
the chief officer could you give some
more details if at all possible just
perhaps on the ages or the genders of
those who have lost their lives uh
Julian you'll understand that I'm not
yet in a position to do that but my
commitment is in future events like this
I'll be able to provide more information
when that information is known
thank you um to the Chief Fire officer
could you please um just paint a picture
of the scene last night and of the surf
search operation and what prompted you
to to move from that search and rescue
to that recovery phase
yeah thank you um I I've no doubt that
you will have seen the footage of the
initial explosion captured on camera
um and so from that you'll you'll
already have a picture in your mind I
think of the the level of Destruction uh
of the site
um of course an event like that clearly
causes an awful lot of physical
destruction in terms of percussive
Destruction things moving things being
hit but also uh you know the collapse
and fires and so there was a great deal
to do for the for the first arriving
fire Crews uh in order to address the
immediate and most pressing hazards as
they face them so that they could go
about their their business in further
stages if you like but also of course
trying to evacuate and facilitating
evacuation as well to to to stop a very
very bad situation for becoming worse as
much as they possibly could in those
early moments
um coupled to that an explosion an
incident of that magnitude for an island
of our size was inevitably going to
require Mutual Aid that's been a
planning assumption for many years I've
been around long enough to have seen and
experienced a mutual Aid protocol being
used in the 1990s as well so you know we
understand when these situations arise
that that one of the early things we
need to do is make sure that we get the
support that that is needed but is also
I think it's really important to stress
the support that is offered the the
response from my colleagues and I know
that this is the case for the other
Emergency Services as well but the
response from my colleagues nationally
as well as specifically in Hampshire in
the Isle of Wight rescue service has
been nothing short of energetic positive
Timely
and would you just be able to tell me a
little bit more about the cordon and how
that area of town
um will be how it will be going forward
um I think that I I mean what because
we've moved into the phase that we've
moved into now uh it has gone from a
scene which is effectively in terms of
safety managed by the fire and rescue
service
um to a scene which is being managed by
the police service because of course
we've moved from a search and rescue
phase into a search phase
um therefore you know I I don't know
what will happen to the the further and
out accordance the Unicorn remains
around the most hazardous site that's
that's that's you know that and of
course within that inner cord and there
are zones of operation
um but but they are concentrated around
the site and of course then
concentrically they move away from that
site
and finally sort of to the police chief
um would you be able to tell me exactly
how many people have been accommodated
elsewhere and what the plan is for them
and can the community do more to support
first of all I think it's in the region
of 40 but I'll check on that number
um similar to the Chief Minister I I am
personally overwhelmed by the amount of
support that has been provided I've even
received personal texts from uh Hotel
managers other residents who wanted to
give up their rooms I think that is
absolutely typical of the community that
we're in I am very confident and that
this issue is raised every time at the
Strategic coordinating group meetings is
about how those people who have had to
leave buildings nearby are being
accommodated they have all been
accommodated and the island effort is
remarkable frankly
good afternoon Ashley harunag from Sky
News
um please can you give us an idea of
what time either last night or this
morning you made the call to go from a
search and rescue operation to a
recovery one and sorry what led to that
assessment was it thermal imaging
um yeah please could you tell us
understand yeah thank you
um I I can't remember at the top of my
head exactly we obviously we have a log
of all of the timings
um but um but I know that the incident
happened around about four o'clock I
think that I was contacted at around
about 4 30
um and I know that it was very it was
around about that time that we knew and
the decision locally was made that we
needed to invoke those processes it was
a very early morning call with
colleagues uh in Hampshire in the Isle
of Wight fire rescue service I was on
that call and then of course that that
process sort of evolved very quickly
into a formal request which was accepted
immediately by hampering the Isle of
Wight rescue service I can't remember at
the moment exactly what time that was
but it was extremely early in the event
um the reason that we did it um much
like the answer I gave earlier on
actually is is
just looking at the size of and scale of
the scene and of the destruction and and
a professional assessment of the
challenge ahead with a very
long-standing assessment and
understanding of the size and capability
of the fire rescue service in Jersey a
brilliant fire rescue service but of
course it's a small Farm Rescue service
for a small jurisdiction
um so so
um it was very obvious and that's why
we've had those assistance agreements
and mutual Aid protocols in place for a
long long time